the Surrey Countryside is perhaps better
known for its forests than its fossil
fuels
but a short walk from here is an oil
Reserve deep underground campaigners
want to keep it there it's not just in
my backyard oil produced is sold on the
global market so it could be burned
anywhere on the planet and of course
once it's in the atmosphere it can
impact anybody on the planet
the site was approved four years ago by
Surrey County Council but has faced a
legal challenge ever since and next
month will go to the UK's highest court
the site Behind These Gates could
extract two hundred thousand barrels of
oil which may sound like a lot but the
UK already produces around a million
barrels of oil every day but although
this site is quite small the
significance of the court case is so big
that another fossil fuel company based
hundreds of miles away is also getting
involved
West Cumbria mining wants to dig up coal
here in the Northwest it's been allowed
to intervene in the Surrey oil case so
it can Aid the Court's understanding
both developments hinge on the same
issue
when assessing a Project's damage to the
environment do you consider only the
emissions from extracting it or also
from when it's actually burned
Downstream
the question is so contentious that
three other groups are also intervening
including the environment Watchdog if
the Court decides that you have to take
into account the downstream impacts then
every fossil fuel development will be
assessed as having a massively negative
impact on the environment this case
could be the beginning of the end of new
fossil fuel extraction in the UK
industry says we cannot afford for that
to happen it's clear we are going to
need oil and gas out to 2050 and Beyond
even with huge growths growth and
Renewables there's that there is as
incontrovertible this case of where we
get it from not if we need it or not
with plenty more decisions on oil and
gas sites on the horizon the industry
will be keeping a close eye on the fate
of this one Victoria Seabrook Sky News